la palme d'or du 55e festival de cannes
devrait être décerné dans quelques
minutes
ce soir en tout cas l'ultime film
projeté sur la croisette sera le 38e
long métrage d'un habitué du festival à
now ladies and gentlemen signé claude
lelouch avec jeremy iron c'est patricia
kaas la chanteuse qui fait ses grands
débuts au cinéma
sabine gorny olivier tu y es tu un homme
une femme et un gentil refrain vraiment
ça ne vous rappelle rien signé de
l'ouche 38 films déjà depuis 1966 et la
palme d'or qui le consacra cinéaste à 28
ans ce qu'il aime dans le cinéma c'est
toujours les sagas et les fameux
je crois je suis un aimant et que
l'histoire viennent à moi c'est mon
fonds de commerce on dit aujourd'hui on
dit c'est une histoire allait lellouche
mais toutes les histoires de mes films
je les ai vécus directement ou
indirectement un homme jérémy aerents
une femme patricia kaas lui ou ténébreux
malheureux gentleman cambrioleur
briseurs de coeurs elle chanteuse de
piano bar à ô désespoir
que croyez vous qu'il arriva et à vous
et pour avoir la chance de se noyer dans
ce regard là on aurait tous voulu
s'appelait patricia quand on se retrouve
devant jérémy haurie mon dieu c'est pas
qu'un acteur c'est un grand acteur
c'est un homme séduisant cc était là dès
ses vêtements qu'elle ne pas faire
d'enfant il ya 14 ans mademoiselle
chantait déjà le blues 14 millions
d'albums plus tard la belle lauren fait
ses premiers pas au cinéma
un rôle qu'elle doit aussi à son joli
minois tu cherchais un visage
mélancolique
une des choses les plus difficiles a
demandé à jouer un comédien c'est la
mélancolie vous êtes mélancolie que vous
l'êtes pas ce soir en baissant le rideau
pour la cinquante cinquième fois la
croisade fera sans doute elle aussi
saisie d'un petit coup de blues dix
jours de films passion émotion aux
frissons et puis s'en vont sur un air de
jazz parce qu'en france c'est bien connu
tout finit par des chansons